bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe et dorée
dans cette émission reportage une école
pour pister l'argent sale une trentaine
de policiers de magistrats européens de
haut niveau se forment à strasbourg
mission lutter contre le blanchiment
d'argent la corruption l'évasion fiscale
cette formation est une première en
europe financé à 90% par la commission
européenne
simulation de perquisitions cas
pratiques former ensemble des enquêteurs
de plusieurs pays est ce un atout pour
les coopérations à venir c'est ce que
nous allons voir dans le reportage de
charles villanove mais avant à d'autres
sujets les municipales en france vous le
savez elles sont passées une déroute
pour la gauche françois hollande
on a tiré les conséquences en nommant un
nouveau premier ministre
mais déjà les élections européennes se
profile celle valls avait un troisième
tour
françois hollande et sa majorité ont
largement perdu la bataille des
élections municipales
mais une autre arrive trouver 50
milliards d'euros sur la période 2015
le chef de l'état rendez vous avec
l'europe la lutte contre les déficits il
l'a promis des économies de 50 milliards
en trois ans mais où trouver ces 50
milliards d'euros d'économies avant 2017
le gouvernement qui ne parvient pas à
baisser le chômage devra rendre des
comptes à bruxelles en avril sur sa
trajectoire budgétaire dépenses recettes
déficit endettement
il a aussi rendez vous en france avec le
vote au parlement du pad de
responsabilité baisse des charges
patronales contre promesse d'embauché
d'ici là françois hollande aura qu'il
tranchait sur les sacrifices que l'état
les collectivités locales les
fonctionnaires les chômeurs les
intermittents les bénéficiaires de
prestations sociales doivent faire pour
trouver ces 50 milliards d'économies
cela nous concerne tous de près ou de
loin retour du déficit à 3%
hollande demande à demi mots un délai à
l'europe
le gouvernement aura aussi à convaincre
l'europe que cette contribution de la
france à la compétitivité à la
croissance doit être prise en compte
dans le respect de nos engagements
la commission européenne elle-même ne se
fait guère plus d'espoir elle a déjà
prévu un déficit important en france et
demande à paris des mesures
supplémentaires pour le stabiliser ce
déficit au risque de fragiliser la
croissance tant désirée par le chef de
l'état les élections européennes c'est
le 25 mai elle risque de se transformer
en 3e tour des municipales
alors nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par jean marie cavada bonjour
aux députés udi numéro deux de la liste
présentée par l'alternative en
ile-de-france est conduite par marielle
de sarnez alors question toute simple
jean marie cavada est ce que c'est pas
ce dimanche 30 mars au soir du second
tour des municipales que le décor il a
été planté pour les élections
européennes
non il n'ya pas un grand rapport d'abord
je vais faire une observation parce que
parlant aux électeurs et donc aux
citoyens j'aimerais quand même qu'on
dise la vérité et non pas des fantasmes
quelle est la vérité c'est que le front
national en total de voix à fait le même
score qu'il avait fait la dernière fois
c'est à dire quelque chose comme 7,7 et
demi pour cent donc aussi spectaculaire
que l'on puisse considérer la prise d'un
certain nombre de villes il y en a quand
même pas 3000 1 il y en a une dizaine
douzaine et c'est bien normal après tout
puisqu'il puisqu'il ya des électeurs
il ne faudrait pas faire il ne faudrait
pas commencer à avoir ycompris dans
certains médias les yeux de chimène pour
les bleus pour le front national et son
futur scrutin supposée voilà la réalité
ça c'est une première chose
deuxièmement le scrutin européen c'est
un scrutin qui va un peu parlé d'europe
mais aussi hélas pour nous pays en très
mauvais état depuis une trentaine
d'années faut quand même le dire le
déficit ils datent pas d'aujourd'hui
les élections européennes seront des
élections largement de défoulement nous
devons donc mobiliser toutes les forces
républicaines
ceux qui sont au gouvernement sedan
l'opposition qui savent et pensent et
oseront dire à leurs électeurs
la france n'a pas d'avenir hors de
l'europe que maintenant et en gros il
faut cesser de regarder les sondages le
matin et la caméra du 20 heures le soir
il faut dire la vérité
le pays est dans une situation
extrêmement grave et quand ça va mal qui
paye parce qu'ils parlent au dessus
c'est le peuple là bas mais je le dis ça
parce que ceux qui regardent madame le
pays ils vont payer la facture de madame
le pen si un jour elle s'approchait de
pouvoir mais sur ces 50 milliards
d'économies qu'il faut trouver d'ici à
17 ou qu'est-ce qu'on coupe où on va les
trouver il ya plusieurs axes ne pour
pour cette dépense il faut restreindre
la dépense publique
je vais vous donner un seul exemple en
1980 il y avait environ 2 millions 400
500 mille fonctionnaires des trois
fonctions publiques françaises la
fonction des fonctionnaires du statut
national
la fonction territoriale et la santé
trente ans plus tard nous sommes 5
millions 4,5 millions 6 quelqu'un qui
viendrait de la planète mars va se dire
mais ce pays a doublé d'habitants on
était cinquante cinq millions
est-ce qu'on est 110 millions non on est
simplement 65 millions progresser vous
ce qu'on dirait nos services oui
absolument pourquoi ton doubler le
nombre d'administrateurs de la france
alors qu'on n'a pas doublé de population
c'est un laisser-aller pouvant table et
il va bien falloir redresser ça parce
que sinon c'est maintenant que tout les
jeunes générations qui entre de l'emploi
et d'ailleurs qui n'arrive pas à y
entrer vont payer une terrible facture
avec des conséquences sociales et des
conséquences politiques que les
marchands de peur attendent au coin du
bois pour essayer de faire leur propre
fortune
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire en
2013 le déficit on est à 4,3 pour cent
de la richesse nationale bruxelles
rappelle à françois hollande ses
engagements bruxelles va pas lâcher la
faire écouter je suis pas dans la peau
du commissaire en question mais à mon
avis ça va se terminer et il faut que ça
se termine par une négociation mais je
pense que il faudrait que la commission
demande à monsieur hollande des
engagements précis de redressement du
déficit de la réorganisation du marché
du travail c'est-à-dire au fond faire
les réformes que monsieur schneider qui
est à des derniers gros zoom dette en
europe et monsieur art son compagnon de
réformes
ancien patron de volkswagen ancien drh
de volkswagen doit un type qui ne parle
pas de n'importe quoi qui a été reçu
d'ailleurs comme un chien sur un jeu de
tir en france qui n'est pas à la gloire
de nos de nos institutions par
parenthèse
eh bien il faut maintenant que nous
négocions et que la commission demande à
monsieur hollande un engagement précis
sur les réformes en cours est sûre je
dirais le calendrier ou les réformes
vont produire leurs effets jean marie
cavada vous parlez de marine le pen
écoutez ses voeux pour ces élections
européennes
c'est le 25 mai écoutez fév et vous
réagissez juste après
je le répète le front national peut
arriver en tête aux élections entre 20
et 25% jeu mon objectif c'est d'arriver
en tête c'est de créer une prise de
conscience ce que l'union européenne est
en train de faire vivre un autre pays de
l'immense souffrance qui est la
conséquence de la soumission de nos
gouvernements à des règles à des diktats
qui sont aujourd'hui inouïe dans leurs
conséquences en terme de baisse des
salaires des fondements du pouvoir
d'achat de concurrence internationale
déloyale 2 d'augmentation massive du
chômage
thomas jean marie cavada est ce que
c'est possible donc une majorité
d'eurosceptiques au parlement ne
représente pas les eurosceptiques
elles représentent les antieuropéens des
gens de bonne foi d'ailleurs pourrait se
demander pour quelle étonnante raisons
esthétiques étant totalement contre
l'europe il vient se faire salariés en
europe
en ce qui me concerne si je suis contre
la ligue des pêcheurs je vais pas leur
payer une cotisation et encore moins
leur demander un salaire
ceci doit être entendu par les électeurs
il faut de la rectitude
surtout quand les choses sont difficiles
il ya une deuxième chose cette dame elle
a eu un cabinet d'avocats elle connaît
le monde elle avait probablement des
clients des clients qui n'étaient pas
français
elle sait très bien que l'ouverture de
la france sur le monde et notamment sur
l'europe est une nécessité plus de 60%
du commerce extérieur que nous
produisons des produits manufacturés ou
des services notre marché c'est leur
option sort de l'union nos produits
seront renchérit par des droits de
douane en allemagne en italie en espagne
etc
vous voyez un peu les centaines de
milliers de chômeurs que ça va produire
est-ce qu'elle va chiffrer ça est ce
qu'elle va dire le nombre d'emplois
supplémentaires que le fait de sortir de
l'europe va naturellement non non parce
qu'elle sait bien qu on en perdrait
immensément autrement dit je voit se
dessiner dans une sorte d'imprécisions
et d'invectivés une sorte de parti de la
peur ou deux parties du dégoût c'est pas
avec ça qu'on va dresser dans le pays ce
dans les familles qui seraient tentés de
voter eurosceptiques ou anti-européens
qu'est ce que vous leur dit non ne
mélangeons par monsieur eurosceptique et
aux citoyens anti-européen
eurosceptiques épreuve peyriac trois
courants en france madame le pen c'est
les anti européens et de là dedans mais
tout on met tous et même s'il fait pas
beau j'attends le moment où elle va dire
que c'est la faute de l'europe non c'est
pas acceptable
les eurosceptiques ce sont des gens très
intéressants parce qu'il faut leur dire
que ce qui va mal en france le chômage
c'est pas l'europe et madame le pen est
trop intelligente pour beat ne poserait
pas connaître ça et si elle venait ici
plus souvent elles verraient que c'est
pas du tout ça non le chômage c'est
parce que la france n'a pas fait ses
réformes c'est pas les contraintes de
bruxelles
sinon l'allemagne triage où elle a les
mêmes règles que nous il ne faut pas
tromper les gens c'est beaucoup trop
grave et je pense que nous devons nous
lever dans un mouvement de vérité je ne
dis pas que l'europe est parfaite je dis
que sans l'europe deux sont morts et
j'ai pas envie de mourir j'ai pas envie
que mes enfants meurent j'ai pas envie
que le pays ne devienne l'italie en
attendant de devenir l'egypte
j'ai pas envie il ya un dernier sondage
ans qui viennent qui viennent de tomber
qui donne
22% des français voteraient pour l'ump
aux élections européennes pour le ppe
20% pour le point le front national et
18% pour le parti socialiste
ça vous inspire quoi ça m'inspire que
c'est un sondage et je veux pas passer
mon talent comme nantaise qui va venir
on verra bien comment ça s'est un peu
trop tôt aux personnes a fait campagne
donc mais c'est un fait que l'europe a
besoin d'être vain campagne sur quoi
vous alors je vais faire campagne
nous allons madame de sarnez chantal
jouanno numéro 3 et moi c'est à dire
l'ensemble udi et modem de l'enfer
campagne sur une chose simple si vous
pensez que l'europe c'est l'avenir des
réformes en france c'est la façon de
tirer la france vers l'eau et donc de de
pourvoir des emplois
alors votez pour les européens entre
madame le pen et nous en réalité
y'a personne parce que même quand il ya
des européens ailleurs ils n'osent pas
le dire
tantôt parce que le parti dans lequel
auquel ils appartiennent le redis
moderato cantabile n'en parlez pas trop
quoi
tantôt parce qu'ils n'ont aucune
conception européenne et puis par dessus
tout nous sommes des français nous avons
signé des traités dont nous avons tiré
prospérité et grandeur et même s'il ya
du chômage la france serait petit s'il
n'y avait pas eu l'europe il faut
regarder les choses en face sur ce sujet
qu'est ce que vous inspire ce constat
fait il ya quelques jours par un de vos
anciens collègues jean louis bourlanges
ancien député européen de centre-droit
qui disait ça fait 50 ans qu'on fait
l'europe mais ça fait 50 ans qu'on fait
l'europe avec des gens qui ne veulent
pas de l'europe
oui c'est pas tout à fait faux ça les
gens qui ont dirigé l'europe depuis
plusieurs décennies n'étaient pas des
européens convaincus qu'en les
chrétiens-démocrates et les chrétiens
sociaux ont quitté les gouvernements
européens
notion d'europe c'est beaucoup plus
effondré et le dernier qui était au
pouvoir en europe
c'était jacques delors est ce que vous
diriez à jacques delors qui n'a pas fait
du bien à l'europe et à la france moi en
tout cas je le dirai pas merci jean
marie cavada merci à vous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et maintenant
place aux reportages lutte contre le
blanchiment d'argent la corruption ou
l'évasion fiscale strasbourg strasbourg
on forme des fonctionnaires de tous les
états membres de l'union européenne
contre ces fléaux et ça marche
regardez le reportage de charleville à 9
ok
de loin cela ressemble à une sortie
touristique aux attaques des soins de
près le lieutenant-colonel philip marris
mène son groupe à la baguette
au tec vaisseau en place ok go ils sont
juges magistrats ou encore policiers
venus de tous les pays de l'union
européenne
ils sont 30 à avoir fait le déplacement
objectif apprendre à traquer l'argent
sale pendant trois semaines
il alterne entre pratique et théorie au
programme du jour une simulation de
perquisitions sans arlette heidi
vérification all the people should be a
good non pendant la scène le
lieutenant-colonel traduit et explique
toutes les étapes du contrôle
les élèves ne sont pas novices ils ont
été triés sur le volet dans leurs pays
respectifs
un bloc rare deux doigts levés à ce
qu'est ce que vous avez dans les poches
monsieur and because they found some
jack need is enough for us to search
légitime est justement lors de la
fouille les gendarmes trouvent des
documents attestant de flux financiers
illégaux
c'est là que les enquêteurs entre en jeu
ils vont devoir remonter à la source du
trafic
une mise en situation qu'ils apprécient
tout cela a l'air vrai c'est très
différent dans mon pays
ici ils font ça calmement rapidement ils
savent ce qu'ils font ils sont
professionnels intérieur pour frêche au
nord destin avec ce genre de formation
et plus d'interactions entre les pays on
pourrait accélérer les enquêtes et être
plus efficace à l'avenir la coopération
un des enjeux majeurs de cet
apprentissage entre les contacts et les
informations recueillies l'union
européenne y trouve son compte
c'est pourquoi elles financent la
formation à hauteur de 90% les 10%
restants sont prises en charge par la
ville et l'université de strasbourg
chantal cutajar est à l'initiative du
programme
très vite elle a compris l'importance
d'une collaboration entre les européens
7 l'occasion d'échanger des pratiques ce
qui va nous permettre nous également de
présenter à la commission européenne un
état des lieux des bonnes pratiques voir
ce qui fonctionne bien voir pourquoi ça
ne fonctionne pas at elle est à
l'endroit et qui nous permettra de faire
des préconisations en termes législatifs
ou en termes opérationnels
en matière de fraude fiscale larnack se
niche dans les détails
du coup la formation passe en revue tous
les aspects de l'investigation
financière des cours très spécialisés
qui nécessite parfois des experts
chantal cutajar a fait appel ard le taux
que du service des douanes
il est venu pour expliquer une
escroquerie bien connue des autorités
françaises la fraude à la tva est ce
qu'on vient enseigner c'est un petit peu
la méthodologie détection qui est
surtout la méthodologie d'action le
partage d'informations la nécessaire
restructuration des échanges avec les
pays étrangers puisque par défaut cette
fraude était de type international est
concerné plusieurs pays
la formation est victime de son succès
elle n'organise que deux sessions par an
alors que la demande ne cesse
d'augmenter
l'évasion fiscale est désormais dans le
viseur des états membres et pour cause
elle coûterait plus de 1000 milliards
d'euros à l'union européenne soit plus
de quatre fois le budget de la france
voilà c'est un reportage de charles
villanove nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par françoise castex bonjour
vous êtes eurodéputés nouvelle donne
vous avez quitté récemment le groupe
socialiste pourquoi des socialistes et
je suis encore dans le groupe cic
démocrate jusqu'à la fin la mandature
calcul parti socialiste passe à gauche
j avais jamais certains désaccords
effectivement sur l'orientation du parti
socialiste notamment sur les politiques
d'austérité sur le pacte de
responsabilité mais je suis passionné là
pour parler de ça aujourd'hui
une autre fois à vos côtés jean paul
gauzès bonjour vous êtes euros des
bijoux et ppe
vous confirmez vous reste à l'ump vous
adresse à l'ump voilà alors question
toute simple vous allez venir et de
regarder ce reportage
une école pour pister l'argent sale
madame monsieur le député ça vous
inspire quoi
parce que c'est un début de coopération
l'union européenne a pointé cette ce
problème de la corruption de l'évasion
fiscale il n'y a même créé au sein du
parlement européen une commission
spéciale sur la criminalité organisée
dans lequel je siégeais et ce type de
formation est à une petite échelle faso
à l'ampleur du problème ce qui pour
faire ce qu'il faut initier en formation
mais aussi en complet coopération
institutionnelle entre les polices et en
ce qui me concerne je propose des
mesures beaucoup plus forte avec la
création d'un paquet d'un parquet
européen de manière à ce qu'il puisse y
avoir une saisine d'un juge européen
puisque c'est de la criminalité
transnationale et que quelquefois il est
très difficile de les coincer au niveau
la justice dans un état membre
et puis des sanctions de type
confiscation des biens
et puis une liste noire par exemple des
entreprises qui fraudent qui ne
pourraient plus
soumissionner à des marchés publics jean
paul gauzès on devrait être plus
ambitieux chantier ce reportage à peine
à 2 deux idées simples
la première c'est que un certain nombre
d'événements ne peuvent être traités au
niveau rover et on voit là l'utilité de
l'union européenne
la coopération nécessaire entre les
états pour éviter qu'il y ait des
endroits d'un endroit où de protection
conforte deuxième aspect c'est tout sur
lequel moi je souhaite insister c'est la
différence entre la fraude fiscale est
ce qu'on pourrait appeler l'évitement
fiscal la fraude fiscale c'est un délit
ce doit être poursuivie réprimer avec
les dispositifs qui était voté
l'évitement fiscal c'est le fait qu'un
contribuable et celle également
légalement de ne pas payer des impôts
plus que il a envie de faire et cet
évitement fiscale peut être lui même
éviter tout peut être évité si on a une
meilleure harmonisation fiscale au
niveau européen à ce moment-là il durera
pas des niches ou des possibilité
d'échapper à l'impôt mais on ne doit pas
mélanger la fraude et l'évitement fiscal
ou ce qu'on appelle aussi l'optimisation
fiscale
voilà alors madame la députée monsieur
le député la directrice de l'école elle
vous interpelle vous les parlementaires
ne vous pose une question on écoute sa
question et vous réagissez juste après
seriez vous prêt à initier à soutenir
une résolution pour demander à la
commission européenne d'adopter un
instrument juridique européen pour
promouvoir les investigations
financières à l'échelle de l'union
européenne
voilà une résolution pour demander à la
commission de promouvoir les
investigations financières à l'échelle
européenne c'est ce que vous demande la
directrice de l'école c'est possible ou
pas bien sûr que c'est possible quand je
vous parlais tout à l'heure d'un parquet
européen
c'est à ça que je pensais il ya eu des
votes déjà du parlement européen sont
favorables à l'institution de ce juge
européen là où je rejoins jean paul
gauzès s'est il vraiment plus d'europe
qu'il faut pour traiter ce sujet et ce
parquet pourrait avoir des sections
spécialisées dans la prod silence hier
dans la traite des êtres humains pour
traquer et pour juger et pour
sanctionner toute la criminalité
organisée au niveau transnational aille
à la fraude et l'évasion fiscale fraude
évasion fiscale c'est 2 milliards
d'euros qui plombent qui plombent leur a
bien quelques jours l'autriche
luxembourg à se sont mis d'accord ils
ont dit au revoir aux secrets au secret
bancaire après six longues années de
blocage les dpi ont fait accepter d'y
mettre fin c'était il ya quelques jours
ça va changer quoi concrètement jean
paul gauzès alors pour répondre à une
question de la directrice je réponds oui
oui sans réserve
deuxièmement le parlement a voté très
récemment une résolution sur la question
de la fraude fiscale et nous avons une
très large majorité j'étais un des co
signataire avec mes collègues de gauche
de ce texte sur et donc sur la fin du
secret bancaire
effectivement le texte était bloqué pour
la petite histoire le dossier sur la
fiscalité des parcs a été terminé du
côté du parlement à la fin du mandat
précédent le rapporteur était quelqu'un
qui a fait son chemin depuis c'est
benoît hamon et puis pendant cinq ans
les choses ont traîné nationale les
choses ont traîné et maintenant
finalement l'autriche et l'a suivi il a
su et l'autriche et le luxembourg ont
accepté l'échangé automatique
d'informations ça va changer c'est que
ça ne sera pas aux administrations
d'aller pêcher des informations là où
elles ont des soupçons
elles recevront directement les
informations utiles concernant les
mouvements financiers
et c'est une bonne chose parlons
maintenant de la corruption la
corruption pense aux pays du tiers-monde
finalement ça concerne aussi l'europe
il ya ce sondage
cette étude eurobaromètre sur la
perception des européens plus des trois
quarts des européens estiment que les
pots de vin les emplois fictifs
les détournements publics et autres
financements occultes partis politiques
je cite sont très répandus très répandue
en europe c'est leur perception il ya
les faits aussi pour la première fois la
commission européenne il ya quelques
jours a présenté un rapport sur la
corruption qui représenterait 120
milliards d'euros chaque année dans les
est-ce qu'on manque de volonté politique
pour combattre ce fléau france à ce
qu'elle se croit que déjà à l'intérieur
même des partis politiques et des
groupes politiques
il faut être intransigeant et c zéro
tolérance sur la corruption des élus en
fait les groupes de pression des lobbys
au parlement européen non mais si vous
achetez non moi c'est pas la corruption
et les lobbies par la corruption
tu viens vous parler de présenter ses
positions et défendre ses intérêts il
fonce et centre à nous à nous était bien
à côté c'est de la cohésion
oui mais en ce qui me concerne on m'a
jamais proposé de valises de billets
donc je dois pas accepter des valises de
billets mais on a vu il ya eu cette
fameuse caméra cachée vous savez qu'il
ya piéger quelques parlementaires en
début de mandat sur de la corruption en
échange de dépôt d'amendements quand on
connaît le finance le fonctionnement du
parlement européen on se demande
d'ailleurs comment on peut payer pour
déposer des mandats mais la réponse du
parlement européen et des groupes
politiques a été immédiate et les
députés européens ont été exclus du
parlement européen donc c'est ce que
j'appelle 0 code zéro tolérance parce
que ce qui met la suspicion sur
l'ensemble de la classe politique c'est
d'eux qu'il n'y ait pas de sanction dans
des rares cas de corruption sont
corruption clientélisme etc sont
dévoilées et que ça n'a pas de
conséquence
donc il faut être intransigeant je crois
que vrai mais moi ce qui me rend tout de
même quelques fois un peu étonné c'est
c'est de voir qu'on connaît si bien le
montant de la corruption parce que
si on connaît le montant de la
production c'est qu'on en connaît
parfaitement les rouages et donc si on
entend des rouages on peut prendre des
mesures pour essayer d'éviter ces comme
l'évasion fiscale où il s'est fait en
deux milliards si vous n'avez pas
l'évasion fiscale vers y ait moins
d'impôts mais alors pourquoi on prend
pas les mesures
je crois qu'il ya eu un problème de
volonté politique c'est vrai parlons un
peu de politique politicienne at elle
qui vous concerne les élections c'est le
25 mai comment elle se passe la campagne
jean paul gauzès vous êtes vous n'êtes
pas sûr d'être réélu a pourtant vous
êtes cité comme étant l'un des députés
les plus influents et les plus est en 3d
les élections c'est toujours un peu
aléatoire 1 c c'est le jeu de la
démocratie
je suis en troisième position dans une
région nous avons au total 10 des
poulies à dix députés et nous avons
quatre sortants donc on peut penser
compte tenu des résultats de du week-end
précédent que ça devrait les mais on
n'est jamais sûr françois scassa de vous
vous avez été carrément évincé de la
liste ps oui on peut dire ça comme ça
quoi la justice a pas de justice et non
je sais pas c'est sans doute aussi le
mode de fonctionnement le monde de
constitution des listes
on est des grands d'europe et au mercy
nous avons celui resté avec nous sur les
chaînes parlementaires